okay
um
that way
right
earlier
oh
right here
okay
back by popular demand um if he decides
he's not going to be an economic expert
anymore he might have a future uh in our
business um or in our in the press
office um so back philippe is back uh
he's gonna give some brief comments at
the top take a few questions uh then
we'll do uh some briefing after then and
i'll just stay at the top for anyone who
needs to leave for tv feel free to go
it's all fine i will turn it over to
delete now
thank you jen good to see all of you
again but this is a briefing i never
wanted to give um
i'd like to start by saying the prayers
of the entire world
are with the people of ukraine today as
they suffer an unjustified
unprovoked
and premeditated attack by the russian
military forces
president biden has said from the start
of this crisis if putin chooses to
invade the cost to russia will be
immediate and profound
to its financial system to its economy
to its technology base
and to its strategic position in the
world
as the world has now witnessed putin has
made his choice
he rejected diplomacy and chose war
and today the president has announced
our response
because of putin's choices his flagrant
violation of international law
and his utter disregard for the
principles that underpin peace and
security across the world we will now
ensure his decision is remembered as a
strategic failure
today we impose an unprecedented package
of financial sanctions and export
restrictions in lockstep with our allies
and partners
that will isolate russia from the global
financial system
shut down its access to cutting-edge
technology and undercut putin's
strategic ambitions to diversify and
modernize his economy let me walk you
through a few specifics and i'll be
happy to take questions
on financial sanctions i started this
podium on tuesday
and said uh
we would impose the most severe
sanctions ever levied on russia
if putin proceeded with the invasion
today we're following through
we will impose sanctions on russia's two
largest financial institutions
spare bank and vtb which together hold
more than half of the russian banking
system's assets
over 750 billion dollars in total for
vtb we will freeze all of its assets
touching the u.s financial system
and prohibit u.s persons from doing any
business with the bank
for spare bank we will sever its access
to the u.s financial system
we'll also freeze the assets of and
prohibit any business dealings with
three additional russian banks with
combined assets of over 70 billion
dollars
we'll also restrict u.s investors from
providing debt or equity financing for
13 of the most critical
uh russian state-owned enterprises which
combined have estimated assets nearing
1.5 trillion dollars
and finally we'll also impose sanctions
on the executives
at these state-owned institutions
as well as additional russian elites who
are complicit in putin's kleptocracy
and their family members
those who've shared in the kremlin's
corrupt gains and stored their wealth in
yachts and luxury condos and fancy cars
will now share in the pain of these
measures
in terms of the financial impact as i
said these are the most impactful and
significant sanctions
the u.s has ever taken
but financial sanctions are just one
part of our response we're also
unveiling today an expansive and
unprecedented set of export restrictions
developed in historically close
coordination
with the european union australia japan
canada new zealand the united kingdom
and taiwan
these new measures include sweeping
restrictions on russian military end
users to impair putin's military
capabilities
and will also deny exports across russia
to sensitive cutting-edge technology
primarily targeting russia's defense
aerospace and maritime sectors
in total the united states and our
partners will effectively be cutting off
more than half of all high-tech imports
going into russia
this includes curbing russia's access to
advanced semiconductors and other
foundational technologies that russia
needs to diversify and modernize its
economy working in tandem these
financial sanctions and the export
controls
will undercut putin's aspirations to
project power on the world stage
and those impacts intensified
dramatically just today the russian
stock market plunged over 30 percent at
one point before being halted by local
regulators
russia's currency the ruble weakened to
its weakest value on record against the
dollar
before the central bank intervened
and the price the market is charging the
russian government
to borrow
is now above 15
these impacts over time will translate
into higher inflation higher interest
rates lower purchasing power lower
investment lower productive capacity
lower growth and lower living standards
in russia to be clear this is not the
outcome we wanted
it's both a tragedy for the people of
ukraine and a very raw deal for the
russian people
but putin's war of choice has required
that we do what we said and to ensure
this will be a strategic failure finally
let me just say a few words about the
impact of russia's choices on the u.s
we've intentionally scoped our sanctions
to deliver severe impact on the russian
economy while minimizing the cost to the
us as well as our allies and partners to
be clear our sanctions are not designed
to cause any disruption to the current
flow of energy from russia to the world
we've carved out energy payments on a
time-bound basis to allow for an orderly
transition of these flows away from
sanctioned institutions
and we provided other licenses to
provide for an orderly wind down of
business
let me just stop there and take your
questions
i just had a real quick question you
said it would take some time
before it affects the
economy inflation what's the timetable
how long do you think it will take until
you have demonstrable results
well look um
these are these are costs that build
over time and as i mentioned i think
last friday
any leader whether you're an autocrat or
a small d democrat has to pay attention
to the living standards
of your country
and already we're seeing the effects of
these measures and the signaling that we
provided over the last three months
before these sanctions were implemented
inflation in russia was 8.7
the government's borrowing costs had
spiked above 10 percent the ruble had
lost almost 15 percent of its value and
today those those costs escalated
dramatically now it's going to be up to
president putin to decide ultimately how
much cost he's willing to bear what we
control is to make sure this will be a
strategic failure not just because of
the sanctions but also because of the
export controls because of europe's
accelerated diversification away from
russia in terms of its energy supply uh
due to our fortification of nato's
eastern flank and due to the renewed
energy and unity and determination by
the west to stand up for our values and
advance our principles
you're in it for the long haul right
it's i mean you're until you see the
results that you want we understand that
these costs will accumulate over time
you've just laid out all of the actions
that the us that our allies have taken
at this point as you understand the
questions though at this point are about
the actions you have not yet chosen to
take at this point specifically the
swift system and sanctioning president
putin specifically himself what are the
uh triggers at this point are there
actions that president putin might still
take you're expecting that would trigger
those sanctions or what are the
potential complications especially about
sanctioning putin personally so i
understand a lot of questions about
swift and about sanctioning president
putin and lots of other measures uh that
could be mentioned but let me say this
i think today was a demonstration that
we mean what we say
we delivered on what we said we would do
in terms of imposing costs so when we
say all options are on the table
and that we're prepared to continue to
ratchet costs higher
it would be a mistake to doubt that
resolve
but let me let me also step back and say
that when we consider which sanctions to
apply
we're not cowboys and cowgirls pressing
a button to impose costs we follow a set
of principles we want the sanctions to
be
impactful enough to demonstrate our
resolve and to show that we have the
capacity to deliver overwhelming costs
to russia that's one
number two we want them to be
responsible
to avoid even the perception of
targeting the average russian civilian
and of course unwanted spillovers back
to the u.s or the global economy
number three we want to stay coordinated
and so we calibrate our sanctions to
maximize the chance that we move in
lockstep with our allies and partners
number four they should be flexible so
that we can escalate or de-escalate
depending on
backs on the ground and lastly as i
mentioned before they have to be
sustainable these sanctions work over
the long term that's what will guide our
design okay
in light of the sanctions that were
announced against individuals and
entities in belarus can you tell us
whether there are sanctions against any
other countries that are being
seriously considered at the moment and
what is the line that a nation would
need to cross in this conflict for them
to
receive be on the receiving end of
sanctions from the u.s well the belarus
measures were about delivering costs to
a country that aided and embedded what
we saw uh yesterday and overnight but i
have nothing else for you in terms of
other countries uh being targeted
oh do you have a question oh yeah yeah
definitely i know i didn't mean i i i'm
using the arms here
thank you
i wanted to ask you about the some of
the carve-outs uh there are general
licenses for more than a dozen areas
agriculture energy and you just said
that the importance is to limit the
impact on americans but i was hoping
that you could say
is there a percentage that you can share
of the number of exemptions that make up
the overall transactions so the general
licenses
how many how many trans what percentage
of the transactions are under those
licenses
i i would refer you to treasury nofak
for the for the details on what exactly
uh is being exempted and the percentage
of business that would be included
i mean is it a small percentage is it a
high percentage i would go back to the
the principles of our design um the
measures themselves and the exemptions
are balanced so that we can deliver
overwhelming costs um while not having
unintended consequences and so that's
the that's the principle but as to the
specifics i'd refer you to treasury
wouldn't the oil be a large potential i
mean considering how important it is to
uh to russia's bottom line
well look um where we have an asymmetric
advantage is in foreign capital and
cutting edge technology
and so that's where we're that's where
we're delivering the most concentrated
impact when it comes to energy
this is the one area
this is the one area where russia has
systemic importance in the global
economy we know it's the second largest
natural gas producer in the world it's
also the second largest crude oil
produced in the world
that's not to say that we have a
dependence on russia russia depends on
those revenues just as much as the world
needs its energy
but we're not going to we're not gonna
do anything which causes an unintended
disruption to the flow of energy as the
global economic recovery is still
underway
two quick questions actually one if
putin takes key does that trigger
additional sanctions specifically that
scenario
uh not going to speculate on particular
hypotheticals
you mentioned the timeline you've been
asked about the timeline the president
said in one of the answers to his
questions today said let's have a
conversation in a month to see if these
sanctions are working
my question is what happens in the
meantime russia is taking over parts of
ukraine major parts of ukraine as we
speak so the world just sits back and
watches that happen until these
sanctions take effect
look we can't dictate putin's actions
what we can do is what's with our
control and to make sure this is going
to be a strategic failure
for russia and so over the course of the
next month what you can expect
is that we'll see an intensifying
negative feedback loop in russian
markets and i've described the elements
of that you'll see record capital out
flight uh capital record capital
outflows
you'll see a weaker currency you'll see
higher inflation you'll see lower
purchasing power you'll see lower
investment and that negative feedback
loop the velocity of it is going to be
determined by putin's own actions
and so that's what you should expect on
the financial side sanctions front on
export controls what you can see is that
over time this is going to atrophy
russia's capacity to diversify outside
of just oil and gas and to modernize
the strategic sectors that putin himself
has said
he wants to develop aerospace defense
i.t lasers sensors
these sectors all depend on foundational
technologies designed and produced by
the west you will begin to see a
chilling effect
take hold in russia as those inputs are
denied
thank you
for weeks now administration officials
have repeatedly said yourself included
that these sanctions are meant to deter
and prevent
putin from moving forward from acting
can you help us understand why the
president said today that no one
expected the sanctions to prevent
anything from happening
and then secondly on a quick one on
putin sanctions
without talking about when you might
trigger them can you help us understand
what harm they would do to him
personally if
you were to sanction putin
look on your first question we don't
usually engage in
hypotheticals up here at this podium but
let's play this out had we had we
unleashed our entire package of
financial sanctions preemptively i think
a couple of things might have happened
number one
uh president putin might have said
uh look
these people are not serious about
diplomacy they're not engaging in a good
faith effort to promote peace instead
they're escalating and that could
provide a justification for him to
escalate and invade
secondly he could look at it as a sunk
cost in other words president putin
could think i've already paid the price
why don't i actually take what i paid
for which is ukraine's freedom
so that's that's what we wanted to avoid
look
ultimately ultimately
the goal of our sanctions is to make
this a strategic failure for russia and
let's define a little bit of what that
means
strategic success in the 21st century is
not about a physical land grab of
territory
that's what putin has done
in this century
power strategic power is increasingly
measured and exercised by economic
strength by technological sophistication
and your story who you are what your
values are can you attract ideas and
talent and goodwill and on each of those
measures this will be a failure for
russia
i keep texting you
do you but is it fair to say no one
expected the sanctions to prevent
anything you certainly expected that
right look we
signaled as clearly as we could what was
coming
if russia proceeded with an invasion
um
you know
as i mentioned before
economic costs of this severity
generally matter
to any leader because of the effect it
has on on his people's living standards
in this case putin made the wrong choice
[Music]
to still reject russia from the swift
system can you say if the us is still
intensely working to pressure allies to
do the same how intensely are you guys i
can't comment on what the uk's position
is i'm not uh i'm not going to speak to
that but what i'll say is the sanctions
measures we impose today i think without
question were the most consequential
ever levied on russia and arguably the
most consequential ever levied in
history if you look at the aggregate
financial impact on russia
so that's why we took the measures that
we did and we did so because we could
move in lockstep with our allies and
partners and because we think the
spillover effects will be manageable
[Music]
a realistic live round is the u.s really
still making an intense effort
for this or is it essentially this being
swift
look again i'm just going to repeat all
options are on the table and we're we're
prepared to ratchet costs higher at a
time and place of our choosing
and you know president putin should take
that seriously after what he saw today
just two questions first if you were to
sanction uh vladimir putin
do you know where his money is
not going to comment on that
and secondly um
if uh
what is the message to russia at this
point on what it would take to roll back
relieve some of the sanctions that you
put in place today
look um the the road to diplomacy is
always
open
diplomacy is never dead but in the
current circumstance in the immediate
aftermath of an invasion
um that that option is not available
right now we're imposing severe
consequences on russia for its decisions
uh if there were to be a shift in in
russia's strategic choices that upheld
core principles of respecting your
neighbor's borders respecting your
neighbor's sovereignty allowing
countries to have the freedom to set
their own course and their own destiny
that would be a different situation but
that's not where we are
tyler mr um you uh suggested that there
are things that still remain on the
table but as you walk through the
hypothetical scenarios of trying to keep
diplomacy open um you you said that they
have now crossed the line but if you're
saying there's still more on the table
do you expect things to get worse in the
coming days that russia will continue to
move forward is that the intelligence i
know you guys have been quite
transparent about the intelligence you
have are you keeping things back because
you think the situation is going to get
worse i think we've we've been
transparent in to a remarkable degree
one aspect of that transparency is by
saying
we can't get into president putin's head
and so your question requires me to
speculate on on how he's thinking about
next steps and i simply can't do that
just in terms of u.s intelligence and
the way that you are planning out the
different sanctions you have and and
keeping things on the table
is that a sense that it it will get
worse because you want to hold things
back
look our job is to be prepared and
manage risks all manner of risks uh and
that's what we've been doing over the
past three months as this crisis
intensified we'll continue doing
[Music]
the that the russian energy industry is
totally off the table is that what
you're saying believe
what i'm saying is that our measures
were not designed to disrupt in any way
the current flow of energy from russia
to the world now
um we have also said we're going to cut
off russia's access to cutting-edge
technology that technology can be used
across many sectors
uh and and so as it relates to russia's
long-term productive capacity
we are seeking to degrade that capacity
but nothing nothing in the short term as
it relates to energy
thank you for joining us
appreciate it
okay i know it's late but we will get to
as many people as possible i just wanted
to note a couple of things um at the top
for all of you uh one uh usaid put out
an announcement that they've deployed a
dart or disaster assistance response
team to respond to humanitarian needs in
ukraine uh this dart team which is
currently based in poland is working
closely with european allies and
partners who will be on the front lines
of the response the team will lead the
us government's humanitarian response to
help address critical needs caused by
russia's invasion of ukraine the dark
comprises 17 disaster experts from usaid
who are assessing the situation
identifying priority needs to scale up
assistance inside ukraine and working
with partners to provide rapidly needed
assistance to communities affected by
the conflict i know a number of you have
also asked me and we've tried to provide
as much detail as possible about
how the president has spent his time
over the last period since last evening
i think we put out a few details but
just to reiterate for all of you
he closely monitored the events on the
ground
from both the oval office and then back
in the residence
over the course of last evening we put
out a few details last night including
the fact that he spoke repeatedly with
his national security adviser jake
sullivan he also spoke with his u.s u.n
ambassador linda thomas greenfield
before she gave that powerful speech at
the u.n last night he received a
briefing from
secretary austin chairman milly
secretary blinken and his national
security adviser around 11 pm
approximately last evening as well and
as you know he also spoke with president
zielenski he continued to monitor
closely into the wee hours uh last night
uh this morning as you all know he
engaged or he met for uh just about an
hour with his national security team
which included
both a full table in the room and full
members from from the cabinet from the
national security team on the screen
during that meeting as a standard he
received an update from of course
defense intel his diplomatic team about
the status on the ground and he has of
course remained closely engaged with
them through the course of the day as
you know he also had a g7 meeting that
lasted a couple of hours this morning
and he also spent an hour this afternoon
on the phone with the leaders leaders in
congress democratic and republican
leaders in congress briefing them on the
situation on a secure call uh briefing
them on the situation on the ground uh
answering questions they had as well uh
so that has been his day to date uh and
he is continuing of course to focus on
other priorities as president uh but why
don't we go to you zeke thanks uh jen
sticking up on that uh has the president
made any additional foreign leader calls
today has he spoken to the president
zelinski um since their their
there's not been another call to
president zielinski i expect as as you
have seen over the past several days he
will continue to have calls with leaders
we will keep you abreast as those happen
and with the us government saying that
it believes that the russian objective
right now is to
decapitate the ukrainian government does
this u.s believe that president zolensky
at this moment is safe
uh we're not going to get into security
uh security questions but we are in
touch with president zielinski and we
are working to provide him a range of
support
and uh presidency in addition to calling
for uh the west to impose to cut russia
off from script and also proposed uh or
called fort demanded i think it was used
in a tweet uh but the uh and its allies
and positive fly zone over ukraine uh i
know the president has said that he
won't put u.s boots on the ground in
ukraine to fight russia is the is
ukrainian air space
is ukrainian airspace uh in play is that
something that
i've seen we've certainly seen his uh
his tweet uh or his request to via tweet
uh but i don't have an update on that
request that's not
off the table with no presents
again i don't have any update on this
point in time or status of the
discussions go ahead thanks just a
follow-up on troops and a few cyber
questions
do you expect nato to call upon major
response force and how many u.s troops
could be called to help in that effort
that's really up to nato as you know we
have a number of troops thousands of
troops that are on call but that is a
decision to be made by the nato alliance
the president said if putin pursues
cyber attacks against our companies our
critical infrastructure we are prepared
to respond so just clarifying does that
first mean that there has not been any
evidence of any cyber attack from russia
against any american companies at this
point
not that we have identified or
attributed at this point in time and can
you i mean aside from past ones that you
were fairly tracking yeah i guess i mean
yeah 24. i understand
can you explain more of the white
house's thinking on kind of this debate
in washington about whether a cyber
attack against a nato ally would trigger
an article 5 response a response from
the alliance
well uh that again is up to the nato
alliance to determine but obviously a
cyber attack does constitute an attack
so that would certainly be a point of
discussion among the nato members okay
one more really fast on the us usaid
disaster yeah my response you just
mentioned a 17 person team
is that enough we're talking about we've
heard you guys talk about potential of
hundreds of thousands of people right
and i think that's an important point
but what i what we're trying to do here
is provide any incremental update on the
status of what our work is and i'll just
note and you may be fully aware of this
but in terms of humanitarian assistance
um we have been the biggest provider of
humanitarian assistance ukraine we've
provided over 52 million dollars in
humanitarian assistance to ukraine in
the past year over the past few weeks
we've committed additional funding and
supplies to humanitarian organizations
there's been a specific need and
therefore a focus on support services
food clean water hygiene shelter trauma
primary health care
are prepared are and we're prepared to
certainly provide a significant amount
more so this is just one step obviously
less than 24 hours after the events of
last night and we will continue to plus
up from here go ahead
there are a number of protests within
russia itself are you monitoring this
what's your message to them
well uh there certainly are and i know
with everything going on this may not
have caught everybody's attention but
let me just uh note that um you know
today we're seeing russian people uh in
the streets open letters from leading
russian journalists cult and cultural
figures denouncing president putin's war
of choice and reports of russian mothers
concerned about the reckless deployment
of their sons to this fratricidal war i
think it's important to remember back in
2014 when they didn't even acknowledge
that they were sending russian soldiers
they didn't even acknowledge when there
were body bags coming back from ukraine
into russia and there is an outcry in
the streets by russian people by by more
russian people than i think many would
expect so despite putin's crackdown at
home dissenting views remain and i think
that's important to note to publicly
protest against president putin and his
war as a deeply courageous act their
actions are the world that despite the
kremlin's propaganda there are russian
people who profoundly disagree with what
he is doing in ukraine one more speaker
pelosi is talking about sending 600
million dollars in lethal aid to ukraine
is this something you support we are in
uh conversations uh with uh congress and
i mentioned the president spoke with
leaders uh just earlier this afternoon i
don't have an exact number but those are
ongoing conversations about uh what
needs the ukrainians have on the ground
in a variety of categories security
humanitarian other economic assistance
go ahead does the us have
any analysis to indicate that there is
dissent or division within putin's
government or is it your understanding
that putin's government is united in
this war it's an interesting question
jamie without getting into intelligence
which obviously we look at i mentioned
obviously russians protesting in the
streets that's not exactly what you
asked about but if you watched the
meeting the president president putin
had uh with
members of his national security team
the other day it was quite striking the
back and forth he had with his intel
chief in that meeting and uh
the the analysis of that is certainly
can be done in an open source manner
given it was quite public but i will
leave outside analysis to uh to give
further assessment of that and as you
know uh we are seeing ukrainians start
to flee the country is the us prepared
to accept ukrainian refugees we are but
we we certainly expect that most if not
the majority will want to go to europe
in neighboring countries so we are also
working with european countries on what
the needs are
where there is uh capacity at poland for
example where we are seeing a an
increasing flow of refugees over the
last 24 hours or throw its flow of
individuals i should say out of ukraine
what their needs are and we've been
talking and engaging with europeans
about that for some time now part of
what you're doing is to prepare for the
united states to accept the president is
certainly prepared for that but i would
just note that because there are a
number of european countries neighboring
ukraine who have expressed an openness
to it and we would anticipate many of
them would want would want to go to
european countries and just one more
quick question the president of course
has repeatedly said that american troops
will not enter ukraine is there any
scenario that's been discussed where
that decision might be reconsidered
the president uh has no intention of
sending uh u.s troops to fight ukraine
that has not changed go ahead um this
was asked the president earlier but i
don't think we got a full answer
yesterday uh
vladimir putin said that he warned if uh
others are involved of such consequences
that you have never encountered in your
history does the u.s understand that as
a threat of using nuclear weapons um
well we can't obviously get into the
minds of president putin as much as he
said that nor do we know
all the specific details about his
strategic posture but we don't see any
increased threat in that regard at this
point in time
good uh just follow up on some of the
cyber questions sure i know that you and
others have talked about
how
the government is on alert the potential
of a cyber attack but can you share like
are there any specific steps that are
being taken that you can share that the
us is doing to protect the
infrastructure power grid u.s banks
well i would say one we've been uh
there's been efforts that have been
ongoing for some time since the
beginning of the administration to
harden um the private sector work the
with the private sector in partnership
to harden their cyber security
protections we've actually seen a great
deal of progress made in the financial
sector it's it's one of the stronger
sectors in terms of protections from a
cyber front uh that we see out there so
it's been ongoing for several months um
obviously uh when there are moments like
this where we continue to watch and look
for what the potential is uh we will we
continue to re to engage closely with a
range of industries about what they need
to do about the potential threats um and
that's something that happens obviously
privately and through a range of
agencies i can see if there's anything
more specific that we can read out to
all
just real quick one follow uh president
biden said they are that the u.s is
prepared if an attack comes there would
uh ris pardon me he said prepared to
respond would that response be a cyber
attack
yes
would that be an equivalent cyber attack
against russia
uh well i would say that uh the
president reserves the option uh to
respond in any manner of his choosing uh
overt or covert
seen or unseen as we like to say and
more available english
but i'm not going to get into specifics
of what that looks like he has a range
of options go ahead thanks on oil prices
again spr does the administration have
an oil price in mind that would trigger
another release from the spr i think not
that we're going to get into detail or
from here uh jj i understand certainly
the question um what you heard the
president talk about today and i can
just reiterate a little bit is that what
has been ongoing both from the president
who's been very engaged in this
having conversations with leaders in the
middle east and other parts of the world
as well as many members of his national
security team
taking whatever steps we can to mitigate
the impact on the global oil markets and
obviously that means increasing supply
obviously a coordinated release from the
strategic petroleum reserve would be
part of that but in terms of what that
looks like or the specifics i'm just not
in a position to get into more details
at this point thanks if the worst
happens in russia either
reduces the flow of natural gas or cuts
off energy all together to europe does
the administration have a good idea for
how long households in europe could last
under that kind of circumstance i i
don't have an assessment of that um from
here i can certainly check with our
economic team one thing i will say that
one of the steps we've been taking
obviously natural gas shortages and
supply is it is an enormous regional
issue one that would hugely impact
europe more than here of course one of
the steps we've been focused on and been
taking is engaging with um partners who
have uh who may have
excess
lng supply like countries in europe
japan for example where they had where
we would were planning to give them some
and now they're going to divert it to
europe um so we've been working to um to
help mitigate um any impact of a further
invasion and a shortage in europe
go ahead some of the activity that we've
seen today in ukraine some of the
clashes had been in and around chernobyl
does the united states have an
assessment of the risk of a radioactive
release
so i do have one actual update on that
as well there's also been there was also
a um report out so let me speak to this
first just so i don't forget um about um
hostages uh around there as well so let
me speak to that first uh we are
outraged by credit credible reports that
russian soldiers are currently holding
the staff of the chernobyl facilities
hostage this unlawful and dangerous
hostage taking which could upend the
routine civil service efforts required
to maintain and protect the nuclear
waste facilities is obviously incredibly
alarming and greatly concerning
concerning we condemn it and we request
their release in terms of a further
assessment i don't have anything more on
that from here you have a read out of
how the president spent
past 24 hours or so uh first i wanted to
ask about his call with president
zolensky did he indicate if he was still
in key did he identify his location at
this point uh we are aware of where he
is located um and we are in touch with
him i would say on that call uh what uh
what they discussed is uh president
zielenski's uh request for the president
to be to condemn the actions of
president putin and the russians and to
engage with other global leaders about
it and that's exactly what he's done
we've seen a number of statements today
from former presidents uh president
obama president bush and also saw former
president trump on television talking
about this as the president you
mentioned
during the afghanistan drowned out he
had been in contact with his
predecessors has he been in touch with
any of his predecessors during this he
has not been today and then in terms of
another domestic priority that was
potentially included in his meetings
today uh given the situation his time
and focus and attention on the supreme
court uh excuse me on ukraine will this
affect the timing of the supreme court
announcement uh we we are still on track
to make an announcement before the end
of the month
we have to do a lot of things around
here at the same time go ahead just to
follow up on the cyber attacks and
article five first and i know you said
that it's up to nato to decide but from
a u.s perspective uh would any cyber
attack against a nato ally trigger
article five or would there be a measure
for what what counts again this is the
conversation we would have with our nato
allies and partners i don't have more
anything initiative to add to it just to
follow up on the supreme court um and he
said you're on on track but has he made
a final decision given there are
basically two days
left
for the end of the month uh not a not a
final final uh and no offer has been no
job offer has been made
go ahead thanks uh just a couple um are
there any concerns or indications at
this point that russia had prepared for
the sanctions that you're putting in
place and kind of develop preemptively
ways to want that impact
well it's an interesting question and
some of it is is hard because it's hard
to get into the minds of president putin
and the oligarchs around him one of the
steps we tried to take is to uh you know
as we were as we were contemplating the
individuals we were going to uh sanction
we
we sanctioned uh family members as well
because what we've seen the tactics
they've used in the past is they've
moved money around and resources around
to family members and we tried to
address that on the front end in terms
of the banking and the financial sector
i mean it accounts for such a large
percentage of of how they do business
that that is it would be a difficult
thing for them to plan and plot against
and if you look to uh just even the
anticipation of the potential sanctions
as the leap was mentioning you know the
ruble is the worst performing currency
in the world right now uh their
inflation is has skyrocketed uh so we're
even seeing in their markets the
anticipated impact even before today and
that's even before the actual squeeze on
uh on the financial sector and in the
country uh so it it feels to me it would
be a little hard to plan around and plot
around given significance of what was
done today and the fact that um when we
sanctioning 10 10 of russia's financial
institutions and these export control
measures which essentially cuts
president putin off from semiconductors
and access to a range of technology he
wants for the future
those are difficult things to uh plu
plan ahead for i guess secondly um does
he mention have any assessment for how
china is reacting to this at this point
whether they are willing to provide
support to russia and how much and has
there been any kind of contact there to
kind of attempt to move them off of any
sport well
in terms of what impact they can have i
mean china
only accounts for about 15 percent of
china and russia i'm not sure you can
double check me on this about 15 of the
global economy if you look at g7
partners in the us and europe it's about
50 right so they cannot cover
uh what the impact of the sanctions that
have been announced in coordination with
europe would how they would impact
russia you know i think from our
perspective as it relates to china well
i can't get into the heads of of what
their thinking is you know this is a
really a moment for china for any
country to think about what side of
history they want to stand on here um
and you know that is certainly the the
the case that we would make publicly and
privately i think you saw that secretary
blinken spoke with his counterpart just
a couple of days ago uh you know the
president's certainly open to speaking
with his counterpart but i don't have
any prediction of that at this point in
time or a timeline what thanks over the
past couple weeks as you've been sending
the alarm on this you've
put the sanctions package together done
conducted diplomacy with the russians
and the rest of the world um
how did uh the ukrainian government use
that time
uh since they've been initially warned
that this was a likelihood did they use
that time wisely to prepare
tell me more about what you mean exactly
well uh you're seeing reports from uh
the streets in russia of i'm sorry in
ukraine of people being surprised uh you
had obviously local and national
leadership in ukraine
uh
telling people to stay calm tournament
to go to work even the day before
uh the invasion began so were they
properly prepared
and was there more that they could have
done
uh in the leader look i think it's not
particularly constructive for us to give
an assessment of that uh what uh what i
can tell you is that our focus has been
on providing uh up-to-date uh what has
turned out to be quite accurate and
transparent information about what the
president putin has was preparing to do
uh which was invade ukraine uh and we
have been very clear with american
citizens who are there we have been
clear with our european partners uh four
months now uh including ukrainian
leadership uh so that has been what our
focus has been um and you know we will
remain a strong support supporter and
partner of of uh president zilensky and
ukraine moving forward go ahead
um following up on the sanctioned
question yeah uh we have heard for for
weeks that these sanctions were at least
in part a part of a strategy that was
based on deterrence as well as
prevention uh today with the president's
comment that no one expected the
sanctions to prevent anything from
happening moving forward do you expect
this later sanctions to prevent any
further advancement or aggression from
russia well i would say that later in
the later in the back and forth or the
press avail he also said when asked um
if sanctions cannot stop president putin
what penalty can and he said i didn't
say sanctions couldn't stop him which
leads me to believe that's not exactly
what he meant he also went on to say the
threat of sanctions and imposing the
sanctions and seeing the effect of
sanctions are two different things and
the way we look at this broadly speaking
and delete touch on this a little bit is
that we do see them as having a
deterrent impact right it doesn't mean
they're 100 foolproof but if you um if
there's a 95 percent chance of russia
invading without the threat of sanctions
and there's a 60 i'm making up these
percentages just to make a point but at
a 65 chance uh that they will with them
you're obviously going to go with the
threat of sanctions because you want to
reduce the threat of an invasion so
there is a deterrent we've seen at the
deterrent impact work at times right
i'd also note that that we are very
clear-eyed about the fact that president
putin not just a few days ago i mean he
gave the speech a few days ago where he
questioned the legitimacy of ukraine as
a sovereign country he's also talked
about how the breakup of the soviet
union was the worst thing that's
happened that's a paraphrase um in
recent uh you know in decades of history
so we are clear-eyed about his ambition
but what the other part of it that we
are quite focused on is the consequences
and the way we see it is you know as
we've touched on a little bit
inflation's skyrocketing the ruble is
the worst performing currency in the
world it was his decision to go to war
it's our choice to make him pay a price
same with the global community and we
believe these consequences are also
going to have an impact
just at the risk of repeating your
question as well i mean the president
did also say you know let's check in in
a month and there has been some
questions about time here it seems like
this is a strategy to use these
sanctions to put pressure on russia to
eventually discourage them to pull out
or to force them to pull out this this
advance so what is the timetable here
you think for when the russian
government will start actually feeling
the impact of these sanctions and
possibly pull out well in many senses
they're already feeling the impact i
mean look at where the ruble is look at
where inflation is look at uh where the
markets are in russia um in terms of how
putin will feel the the impact we just
sanctioned a range of oligarchs around
him we sanctioned 10 financial
institutions
um these are all uh these are all
significant um in enormous steps that
are going to have an impact on him but
in terms of the moment by moment i can't
give you an assessment of that
just there's been a lot of questions
about refugees in the region yeah for
ukrainians that are in the country yeah
as the us especially after yesterday
considering tps or any sort of
protection sure as you know that's a
decision that would be made through an
interagency process led by the
department of homeland security um and i
don't have any prediction of that i mean
i don't have any kind of prediction of
that at this point in time obviously
these these events are just unfolding as
we speak
that conversation i'm not going to give
you any specifics on an internal process
but i would just say again it's an
interagency process and right now uh or
of course in the middle of an invasion
and uh and a uh you know a war in uh in
ukraine go ahead i think jen earlier you
had said that you have to do a lot of
things at the same time one of those
things of course is the state of the
union next year yes can you tell us how
the president this week has been
preparing for that how much time he
spent on this speech and how he's
juggling that with this very busy
schedule that you laid out earlier
tonight yeah absolutely um so in
addition to obviously uh being very
closely engaged and leading the effort
uh on the u.s response uh to the russia
to russia the russian military invasion
of ukraine uh the president has been uh
working with speechwriters uh working
with members of his policy team to
finalize details of his state of the
union uh doing starting to do some read
throughs not too many yet i expect those
will increase in the days ahead i expect
we won't have too much of a preview for
you maybe tomorrow but maybe more likely
this weekend
he's also been engaging with his covid
team
talking about where we are in the state
of the pandemic what's next in the
pandemic he's been working closely with
his economic team on and receiving
updates on the supply chain the
implementation of the infrastructure uh
bill so even as we have all been
understandably focused on the conflict
in ukraine the president has been very
hard at work on a range of issues that
are vital to the american people
my follow-up abc is reporting that the
white house is revamping the coveted
strategy now that hospitalizations are
on the decline should we
expect the president to roll that out in
the speech next tuesday i don't have any
uh preview for you on timeline or format
but
the president has been working and
engaged with his kova team uh for some
time now uh and we're making strong
trung progress
on uh moving toward a time when covet is
no longer a crisis and the kova team has
been spending a lot of time and energy
including with the president working
with experts inside and outside
government local public health officials
and governors uh and this work is
broader than one piece of guidance how
we look at it is we're preparing to stay
ahead of the virus protecting our most
vulnerable keeping our country open
and that is and that is going to look at
everything from the cdc is obviously
reviewing mass guidance but also
how we're going to ensure that vaccines
boosters tests treatments
and other us and other important
components of our medicine cabinet are
available to the american people go
ahead
thanks jen
i had a couple of questions sure nobody
gets good
thanks i had a couple of questions first
a follow-up about some of the
humanitarian needs you've been talking
about you've talked about how much money
and supplies are going to be going but
how are you going to ensure that those
supplies get to the ukraine is there
going to be some sort of air drop and
would the president consider putting u.s
boots on the ground for humanitarian
needs to make sure they get to the
people that need well we we do have
fortunately or unfortunately a fair
amount of experience on providing
humanitarian assistance in
conflict zones uh and we typically work
in usaid specifically has a great deal
of experience
with that working with trusted third
party
entities obviously the government which
remains in power so there's a range of
ways that we would provide assistance in
terms of other mechanisms i don't have
anything to predict for you at this
point in time and then another question
for you and this has been happening why
you've been up at the podium okay
i'm not trying to ambush you but i
wanted to give you a chance to respond
um senator ted cruz is speaking at cpac
and you came up he um
he called you quote unquote peppermint
patty and has encouraged people to boo
you i wonder don't tell him i like
peppermint patty
i so i'm not going to take it too
offensively
senator cruz i like peppermint patty
i'm a little tougher than that but there
you go go ahead hi yeah so um back to
the president's comments earlier today
so he did say to give it a month to see
if these sanctions work however you know
under russia's current assault ukraine
clearly might not have a month or even
weeks so is it fair to say that he is
conceding ukraine to to putin there's
nothing about the president's strategy
or approach or leadership in the world
of building a coalition of
the majority of countries uh you know in
the western world uh to stand against
the actions of president putin uh that
that's that suggests that he is
succeeding anything um you saw him lay
out a set of uh of historic uh tensions
today that will maximize pain on russia
yes uh as we've as we've conveyed
they're meant to have a squeeze over the
course of time but we're already seeing
an impact on the financial markets on
the currency on inflation in russia and
there is a there are unfortunately the
russian people are going to feel the
pain of that uh so i would say the
president is going to continue as he has
for weeks now to work in close lockstep
with european partners to continue to
press uh to press uh from the global
community uh for uh de-escalation as it
relates to the events in ukraine go
ahead
thank you jen if president zelenki is in
danger of being killed or captured and
put on some sort of a show trial would
president biden send
u.s troops in on a rescue mission to get
him out
again we are in touch with president
zolensky who is an important partner we
support him who he is the leader of
ukraine governor the president of
ukraine uh but i'm not going to get into
security steps okay um there's this talk
about a possible forecast for financial
pain particularly at the gas pump
for americans um the president said
today the notion that this is going to
last for a long time is highly unlikely
would he try to ensure that by lifting
some of the restrictions that he's put
in place on the energy industry or
rethinking some projects like the
keystone pipeline
well first of all the keystone pipeline
is not flowing so i'm not sure how that
would solve anything there's also plenty
of oil leases that are not being tapped
into by oil companies so you should talk
to them about that and why
but what the president's talking about
is we certainly understand and he said
this today right may have been in
response to your question i don't
remember but um if there's an invasion
of another country by a big country
there's going to be impacts on the
markets right and we certainly
anticipated that and we anticipate that
as it relates to the global oil market
as well so that's why the president for
weeks now has been engaging with a range
of big global suppliers some in the
middle east others to
see what we can do to ensure their
supply out there in the market to reduce
the impact on the american people and
the u.s is one of the russian oil
industries best customers hundreds of
thousands of barrels per day would the
president ever consider ordering u.s
companies to stop importing russian oil
i don't have any prediction of that at
this point peter we announced some
significant sanctions uh today uh our
objective is to uh in to ensure there is
the greatest economic pain on russia and
not on the russian people but on
president putin and to
minimize the impact on the american
people including companies here in the
united states all right thanks everyone
see you tomorrow
and try to expand back the soviet union
so is this do you all think this is act
one in a multiple country invasion well
i'm not going to make a prediction of
that but we certainly think he has
grander ambitions in ukraine
does he believe that president putin is
going to absorb ukraine into russia when
he says that president putin wants to
re-establish the soviet union is that
what he's saying i think he believes
that as we all do that president putin
has more has grander ambitions in
ukraine hence the military
campaign is continuing thanks everyone
thank you
you